time for wet to watch with blood our
shining star
I'm just gonna take this and make it
about Mr Norman Lear okay myself uh
because we are wishing a huge huge happy
birthday to one of television's most
iconic producers of course we're talking
about Norman Lear he turned 100 years
young yesterday of course he's the man
behind groundbreaking hit shows like All
in the Family and their Jeffersons and
he spoke with our very own Dr John
lapuke who also just happens to be
Norman lear's son-in-law uh and they
talked about the key to success and
longevity
and laughter is the gift of the Gods and
uh there are people in this world that I
had worked with who have made me laugh
in places in my body I would not
otherwise have known existence
that's how deep
I have felt the laughter looks good yeah
why places in your body have you left
that you don't know existed where is
that where is that but I really talks
about laughs sometimes people say to me
Vlad you laugh too much you laugh too
loud nothing but I've been doing that to
you some of you know sometimes people
like no people on social media will be
like tone it down no laughter keeps you
young I just have been doing it since I
was a kid and I love that normally talks
about that yeah he wrote an op-ed for
the New York Times uh and I want to just
pull up a little bit of what he had to
say first of all he said something
really interesting he talked about All
in the Family and he said Archie Bunker
would have voted for Donald Trump would
be a Fox News Watcher but would be
disgusted by what he saw on January 6th
when he saw a man with a flag beating up
Capitol Hill that's a deep dive into the
character yeah
because he wanted he created those shows
to talk about the issues that were
dividing Americans at those times but
never doubted that Archie Bunker loved
his family loved this country and so it
it was a beautiful area right I love
that I got that op-ed in the New York
Times and of course he talks about his
family of course happy birthday Mr
Norman Lear happy birthday